gameplay-wise quantum break has a lot in
common with previous remedy games it
takes fairly unremarkable third-person
shooting and makes it exciting with a
gimmick Max Payne had cinematic bullet
time and Alan Wake had weaponized light
in quantum break it's time based
superpowers there's at least four of
them in fact and when layered together
they make combat really intense and
strategic let's start with the core
shooting it's functional but to be
honest it lacks the feedback you got
when pumping bullets into gears Awards
locusts or binary domains robots
shooting rifles and SM Jesus and
particularly exhilarating by its
effective in that death by a thousand
cuts kind of way grab a shotgun and get
close though and you're working with
Mike Tyson grade uppercuts for that
desperate situation when you run out of
ammo on primary weapons you've got a
very handy pistol with a bottomless clip
weapons in hand it's simply a case of
bouncing around cover and gunning down
everything in your part now that may
sound pretty uninspired and yeah it kind
of is but it's also a solid foundation
on which remedy build something far more
exciting let's backtrack a bit before we
get into that
catchy
bonham break opens with a classic time
travel experiment gone wrong in the
aftermath Ice Man aka Jack Joyce is
being hunted by a mega evil organization
called monarch the upshot for Joyce is
he acquires the ability to manipulate
zero state energy which is essentially
science talk for almost frozen time
think hero from heroes but without the
yotta every five minutes
it's this time bending superpower that
elevates combat the first power time
vision acts like Batman's detective mode
and highlights all threads in red since
different enemy types have distinct
silhouettes this was a handy way of
giving everyone an ocular pat-down with
the time stop ability you can fire a
bubble of frozen time to bring things to
a grinding halt for a few seconds if
you're quick you can freeze a grenade
coming your way and scoot out of the
blast zone or trap an enemy next to an
explosive barrel and well you know what
happens next it's a versatile tool that
has defensive offensive and strategic
applications so it became a bit of a
crutch the third power time dodge is
essentially a blink and if you're
familiar with dragon ball z you'll know
there are few things as awesome as an
instant teleport so when you vanish
right before charging enemy's eyes and
reappear behind them to empty a clip
into his back you can't help but smile
the last power lets you become neo from
the matrix for a few seconds and nullify
all incoming damage time shield was
really useful when we let the power trip
get to our heads and got overwhelmed
which as it turns out was all the time
with all that power you think it'd be
easy to steamroll through everyone but
there are nuances to the way powers work
to stop that from happening since each
ability has a cooldown period you need
to be mindful of recovery times while
time vision can be spammed time stop
time dodge and time shield need to be
micromanage for effective use and trust
me you'll need to start getting really
effective with your powers really fast
your enemies are remarkably aggressive
and pretty intelligent too when in cover
their shower you have bullets to execute
flanks and if you have a tendency of
hiding behind objects they'll use
grenades to flush you out into the open
at times it converge on overwhelming but
that pressure is by design it's remedy
turning otherwise overpowered skills
into tools for survival skirmishes are
painfully intense flirting between power
trips and desperate crisis management
the constant de fleeting and recharging
of abilities gives combat and
electrifying ebb and flow enemies react
to your actions and call out to each
other when you use powers and then start
compensating for them as it turns out
you can also manipulate their teamwork
by concentrating gunfire or you
abilities to follow them into choke
points but those glorious moments when
you're firing on all cylinders the
synergy between abilities gives you a
control over the battlefield that
borders on predatory there's an
explosive energy to moving around the
environment that makes you feel super
heroic and that feeling intensifies as
you upgrade abilities and make them more
powerful there were a couple of niggles
during our hands-on aiming always felt a
bit off regardless of the sensitivity
setting and the act of moving from cover
to cover wasn't particularly satisfying
we could always teleport between points
and move around the environment that way
I always felt like stepping away from
drama but over all this stuff wasn't a
deal-breaker what do you want of course
remedy is also trying some ambitious
things with storytelling in quantum
break specifically how it's delivering
it while the game focuses on Jack
Joyce's side of the story 30-minute
live-action episodes between each act
follow bad guy Paul serene there are
junctions where player choices impact
both stories and neat touches where
live-action focuses on characters that
had otherwise be forgettable but whether
all this will be enough to successfully
unify video games and live action is the
question time will tell but at the very
least it looks like the studio is
anchoring its ambitions on shooting that
feels empowering and thrilling for more
on quantum break check out gamespot com